chromatin immunoprecipitation followed
by sequencing or chipseek is an
important technique to study DNA protein
interaction it can study transcription
Factor binding in different genomic
Locus
now in order to do this process an
antibody specific against a protein or
transcription factor x is used in this
case then the chromatin is sonicated and
fragmented after that the fragments of
Chromatin is pulled down with a magnetic
or a sephiro speed
in this case a magnetic bead all these
DNA fragments that are generated will be
now sequenced with high throughput
sequences
and what is generated is known as reads
that are just string of atgcs later on
these reads are aligned with respect to
a genome Peak is called and this is how
the chip sick data look like presence of
peak simply means those are the region
which are bound by that particular
protein combining with other techniques
like ataxic and rna-seq this can give us
deeper insight about transcription